[MUSIC PLAYING]
HEATHER CROSS: Welcome back--
Heather, again.
EVAN JONES: And
hello from me, Evan.
I'm a technical curriculum
developer for Google Cloud.
If you're a
data-driven enterprise,
you've likely be met with
an explosion of data growth
in recent years.
You need to find the best way
to store all those terabytes
and petabytes at scale.
So welcome to episode 3.
And here's where we're
going to introduce you
to Google Cloud Storage.
It's a storage solution
specifically suited
for your volumes of both
structured and unstructured
data.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HEATHER CROSS: Data doesn't
just mean rows and columns
of numbers anymore.
You may want to start
unstructured data
like messages, documents,
multimedia, files,
web pages, and so on.
Whatever your storage
requirements are,
security, availability and
cost will be your three
key considerations.
Cloud Storage aims to meet
all these requirements.
EVAN JONES: At its core,
Google Cloud Storage
is a massively scalable
storage solution.
And it runs in the
exact same backend
that powers Google's own
applications like storing
Gmail's email messages, the
billions of high-res Google
Photos, and all the data that's
associated with searching
and indexing the internet.
So how do you know which type
of storage option for you
to choose from?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HEATHER CROSS: Cloud Storage
offers four different kinds
of storage,
Multi-Regional, Regional,
Nearline, and Coldline.
You can check them out
in more detail here.
EVAN JONES: So let's
take a few examples.
Say you wanted to store disaster
recovery backups you'd rarely
need, say, once a year.
Then you would consider
Coldline Storage.
You'll get a lower cost
per gigabyte stored,
since you'll be accessing
your data as frequently.
Way on the other
side of the spectrum,
say you wanted to support
streaming data like videos,
games, or your applications.
Here you want to optimize
for high global uptime,
so you want to consider
something like Multi-Regional
or Regional Storage instead.
HEATHER CROSS: The three
key factors you want to keep
in mind when choosing a storage
option is availability--
or how frequently you
need to access the data--
minimum storage duration--
so asking yourself,
are you archiving
monthly backups,
or storing short-lived data?
And finally, pay-per-use
pricing for storage and access.
Whichever option
you choose, they all
offer the same throughput,
low latency, high durability
and security.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EVAN JONES: Securing your
data is always top of mind.
All applications and data
on Google Cloud Storage
benefit from the
same security model
that Google itself uses to
keep its own customers safe
when they use Gmail, Search,
or other Google Apps.
HEATHER CROSS: Data encryption
takes place on the server side
as soon as the data is
received before it's even
written to the disk and stored.
You can also provide
your own encryption keys
for server-side encryption.
EVAN JONES: Google
Cloud Platform
and Google's own infrastructure
is certified for a growing
number of compliance standards
and controls and undergoes
several independent,
third-party security audits.
HEATHER CROSS: You can
refer to our first episode
for more information on the
management of access control
using Cloud IAM.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EVAN JONES: Everything that
you store in Cloud Storage is
contained inside of a bucket.
Buckets are these elastic
containers that hold your data
and the metadata that's
associated with them,
and they help you organize and
control access to your data.
HEATHER CROSS: The Google
Cloud Platform Console UI
can be used to perform
simple storage management
tasks for Cloud Storage,
including the creation
and management of buckets.
This and more
advanced tasks can be
performed using the
gsutil Command-line Tool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
EVAN JONES: And now for the
fun part, hands-on Qwiklabs.
HEATHER CROSS: You
can check out the link
to start the Qwiklab here.
In this lab, you will use the
Google Cloud Platform Console
UI Tool to create, use, and
manage a storage bucket.
EVAN JONES: So we'll be
using the console version
in this lab.
But you'll be able to do
all of these operations
using the command-line,
as well, if you wanted.
And you can check out the
Cloud Storage Quickstart CLI
to learn more.
And keep in mind, this lab
will take you about 30 minutes
to complete.
OK, so here we are
inside the Qwiklab.
The first step that
you're going to be doing
is creating that storage bucket.
Let's go ahead and do that now.
Now for step 2, we're going
to upload some objects to it.
Follow along.
OK, so step 3, we're going to
make these objects publicly
accessible using the Google
Cloud Platform command-line.
Here we go.
HEATHER CROSS:
Well, that's a wrap.
We hope you enjoyed
this episode and would
love to hear more about how you
use or would use Google Cloud
Storage.
EVAN JONES: Don't forget to
keep visiting our on-air webinar
series, practicing
inside of those Quiklabs,
and taking a look at our blogs.
All the links are
found down below.
HEATHER CROSS: You can also
learn more about Google Cloud
Storage through our on-demand
courses on Coursera.
Thanks for watching,
and we'll see you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Check out last week's
episode where we take
a look at machine learning.
We'll discuss a use
case from Google
and run through a section
of our ML Engine Qwiklab.
[MUSIC PLAYING]